Nataly starts off this hour Buffalo New
York hi Natalie how are you hi Dave how
are you better than I deserve what's up
with you alright why I have a I have a
CD that I've had under guardianship
since I was a minor I'd like to go ahead
and remove that guardianship so I can
cash out that PD and pay off some debt
my dilemma is um since it's a
guardianship both my parents names are
on the CD account and unfortunately both
my parents are substance abusers and I
would really not like to do this with
them because I'm afraid they'll ask me
for money
so my dilemma is I'd like to know is if
it's morally okay to go around them
through the courts and get this money
without them okay so they have a
guardianship over you because it was
open for you when you were a minor yes
it was a result of a lawsuit a personal
injury I was injured when I was little
are you sure how old are you now I'm 28
are you sure that that wasn't revoked
upon you becoming a becoming an adult
well when I get my statements it still
has it on my statements have you
attempted to go to the bank and just
cash it out yes and they told me they
won't do anything because the Guardian
is still on there I see okay so did we
did not dissolve because a normal
account would be a custodian account and
that would dissolve when you turn 21
the custodianship would automatically go
away in most cases not not all the time
but in most cases all right so so you
would rather go through a court action
than sit and talk to them yes because um
I just thought I love them but I don't
have any faith in them that you know
that they'll do the right thing if I
were to offer them you know I don't have
any faith in them it's you this amount
oh yeah I know cause you just got a look
at them and form the words it's a it's a
short word it sounds like this no I know
I agree
that's on you yeah so the word know is
going to cost you
five to $10,000 and a bunch of hurt
feelings yeah I would say the word know
mm-hmm I would sit down where they will
say this is my money it's in my name and
we need to have you room I need to have
you sign these two pieces of paper
releasing it to me can we have some of
it no okay well we're not going to sign
the papers you are going to sign the
papers or I'm going to take you to the
court and I don't want to do that
but this is not your money it was my
money was set aside for me
and no you can't have any okay I
wouldn't spend five or ten thousand
dollars to avoid that three sentence of
confrontation great well see I I I
called the court and asked them and as
far as I know all I have to do is pay
that it's like a $75 fee and I have to
tell them why I don't want my parents
with all this
I don't know if there's any more legal
fees than that but okay look that's all
you got to do that's fine but you know
what I thought what I thought I was
hearing was that you had to change your
ownership on an account and it was going
to have to go you know and you're going
to have to hire an attorney everything
else if you can pay 75 bucks walk before
the judge the judge hands it to you and
you want to do that that's fine I don't
any issue with that for $75 I probably
would pay that to avoid the crap you're
talking about but but I wouldn't pay
five or ten thousand dollars to do that
yeah now what are you going to do when
they call you after they hear about this
sometime oh I'm going to tell them no
well they make it know them they make it
notification by the court right I I
believe so I'm not entirely sure how
that so not really going to avoid the
conflict or completely are we no yeah so
you got to get ready okay I get the
little steel install some steel in your
backbone that's exactly what I need to
do yeah and let me let me help you with
that for a second okay okay you grew up
in a family that had substance abuse
okay so you're the child of an alcoholic
the child of a substance abuser which by
nature to the extent you've done some
healing and some learning about that you
may have overcome it but by nature
you've been in a codependent role and
that's what's pulling at you here okay
and codependent just means that we're
enabling people to do things that we
shouldn't allow them to
we're giving a drunk a drink in other
words and when you give these people
money that's what you'd be doing correct
correct absolutely enablers are the
nicest sweetest conflicting conflict
avoiding people you will ever meet
you're a nice person right yes what you
have to do is you have to redefine the
word help because when if you have a
tendency to want to cave and give them
money that would be called enabling and
and that means you've given that you
forget you've defined the word help
incorrectly because you feel like you're
helping them by giving them some money
you're not helping them you're actually
harming them because you're financing
their misbehavior right and so by saying
no you are actually helping and if you
can get that I that truth down in your
spirit it helps you to say no and the
way it helped me was like this lets you
have you got kids record you okay let's
pretend your three-year-old wants to
play in the middle of the street we're
busy cars are going up and down busy
street and they don't like it when you
say no but you're actually helping them
against their will but you're actually
helping them to not misbehave and bring
harm to themselves by saying no and
that's the same thing as your parents
they want to play in the street and
you're saying no and to say yes would be
unloving mmm-hmm to allow your
three-year-old to play in the street and
get killed by a car what kind of mom
would do that right right and you kind
of start thinking about it in those
terms you go well what kind of a
daughter would I be if I helped you
drink yourself into the ditch or help
you do whatever substance you're going
to do I'm going to finance that I'm not
that kind of daughter I'm a daughter
that loves their parents and you kind of
get this thing inside of you and you
equate it to playing in the street that
helped me to kind of get my head around
some of these behaviors because I've
seen people with it for so long and I
deal with it to nobody nobody is an
exception we all want to be nice to
people and we all want to avoid we don't
want to just stir up trouble there's a
few people in a store of trouble but
most don't you know right and so
you got to kind of get yourself ready
for this discussion because it's coming
anyway regardless of which method you
use and I'll send you a book called
boundaries have you ever read that book
I hope not
ah oh you're gonna love it okay it's
you're gonna read it you're gonna go oh
crap I know that guy you know it's just
you're gonna be blown away
you're going to love this book it's one
of my favorite top ten books of all
times dr. Henry cloud boundaries I'll
give it to y'all have Kelly pick up and
we'll send you a copy of it you got a
reading you got to read it before your
parents call because as soon as you do
you'll have a whole different view on
how to handle them and it's not unloving
to say no to a three-year-old who wants
to play in the street as a matter of
fact it is the opposite it is an act of
love to not participate with someone in
their own destruction and you really
have to kind of get that in your head
because that's tough love no it's just
love it's not tough love it's just real
love tough love don't let your
three-year-old play in the street no
it's not it's love this is the Dave
Ramsey show
you